Can you tell how someone looks
based only on how they sound?
Why yes, you can!
Hey everyone, Laci
Green here for D News.
Think of the last
time you talked
on the phone with someone
that you've never met before.
What kind of
assumptions, if any,
did you make about
how the person looks
based on their voice?
A common one would be their
sex, which is usually, but not
always, obvious.
Males with high voices and
females with low voices
can sometimes cause
some confusion.
You may be able to tell
their approximate age.
Grandmas and children do tend
to sound a little different.
But what about what
their voice says
about their height, their
weight, maybe even their race.
A new study coming out of
Washington University and UCLA
a confirms past
studies that people
can tell someone's height
just by hearing their voice.
The participants
heard various voices
saying meaningless
words, and then
were asked to pick who was
tallest, who was shortest,
and to rate five voices
in order of height.
Now, the participants
were accurate
63% of the time, which,
OK, admittedly is not
extremely accurate, but
it's definitely much higher
than if they were
picking randomly.
The researchers
also figured out how
people were able to accurately
guess someone's height--
subglottal resonances.
Sounds fancy, no?
Subglottal Resonances
are the sound
that come from
the lower airways,
below the Adam's
Apple, if you have one.
They describe it like
blowing into a glass bottle.
If the bottle's big, there's
more room for resonating,
and if it's small,
there's less room.
So the taller you are, the
more your voice resonates,
and the more your
voice resonates,
the deeper it sounds.
The researchers
found that people
were able to pick up on very
subtle technical differences
in these subglottal resonances,
which could be particularly
useful for busting criminals.
Because sometimes the only clue
about what a person looks like
happens over the phone.
Another claim that I've
heard is that people
can tell over the phone
how heavy someone is.
Could body weight affect
these subglottal resonances?
Several studies have taken
a look and busted the myth.
So far, none have found
conclusive evidence
that gaining or losing
weight affects your voice.
And what about race?
A person's race is
sometimes connected
to a geographical
area, which is then
connected to a particular
dialect or accent,
and in this case,
it might be easier
to identify someone's
race because you
know where they're from.
But what about when
people of different races
are from the same area?
Then, they all have
similar speech patterns.
Could you tell a black
American from a white American
from a Latino American who
are all from the same city?
Scientists studied
this in depth.
They looked at how
physiology varies by race
and discovered that it's an
enormous, tangled mess, as you
might expect when
you try to pinpoint
physiological differences by
something socially constructed.
But hey, that's a story
for a different day.
The takeaway here
is that controlling
for dialect and accent,
there's no evidence
that you can tell
the race of someone
just by talking to
them on the phone.
Thanks for tuning
into D News, everyone.
If you're interested
in vocal matters,
you should check
out Trace's video
about why we hate our own voice.
And we'll catch you soon
with more science updates.